aside from its title character the most
important personality in the john wick
action saga is winston
the proprietor of the new york branch of
the continental hotel
his past is shrouded in mystery but here
is what can be pieced together about it
from what we've seen so far
winston as of this video has not exactly
fought in the same way
john wick and the rest of his
adversaries have but he has displayed
some of his skill he is shown to be a
pretty impeccable marksman
but probably his most obvious skill is
his capacity for leadership
he commands attention and loyalty by
doing actually quite little
because it is clear that everyone
interacting with him understands who he
is
and where he came from in much the same
way that literally everyone in the
universe interacts with john wick
it's not just the rules giving him clout
winston is known like john is
but it's displayed with negative space
and narrative it's what people don't do
or say around him
up to and including the adjudicator he's
also an excellent negotiator
able to talk down hotheads on the verge
of breaking the continental's rules
with the exception of john when he
decided to kill d'antonio
of course and acting as a power broker
for the hotel
all throughout the third movie if the
high table is composed of an organized
crime elite
the ranks of continental managers must
be as well
rather than being the dons shotcallers
and bosses of families however
it may be reasonable to assume that the
managers of the various branches are the
erstwhile
right hands of those at the table who
better to run a hotel for hired killers
than the best of those among them
it's likely the closest any of them will
ever have to a retirement
and the idea does in fact have a teeny
bit of canonical support through
sofia's characterization we know the
most about how to ascend to running a
continental through sofia
halle berry's character in john wick
chapter 3 parabellum
you do realize that i'm management now
right
i'm not service anymore john she is a
former hunter
and in ascending to the manager position
of the casablanca branch of the
continental she gave up a significant
part of her life
despite the safety the hotels are meant
to provide apparently sophia
either could not or simply chose not to
take her daughter with her
john then hid the girl for her which is
what created the marker relationship
between them
sophia is less than ecstatic about
fulfilling the marker and describes her
life as management as the most peace
she's ever had
despite the loss of her child perhaps
winston was similarly motivated in
seeking to run the new york continental
and later on
fights so hard to retain his lordship
over it and remain in respected in
feared status with the high table
he doesn't just take the job seriously
he relishes it
as he levels the rules against antonio
in john wick 2 when he tries to have
wick's membership revoked
there's a personal flair in how he
enjoys thumbing his nose
at people of theoretically higher status
than him in the third film
the adjudicator gives winston one week
to get his affairs in order before he
will be replaced as manager
as punishment for assisting jon i've
been in service for over 40 years
under the table serving the table
everything is under the table
i understand that you have your
loyalties but this cannot be overlooked
it's unclear if those 40 years of
service is all time spent running the
continental or not
if it is he would have ascended to the
job in his 30s which would likely be a
prestigious thing for someone so young
and such a long time and such a cushy
job certainly could make
anybody a little possessive of it john
wick 2 ends with jon meeting winston at
the bethesda fountain where winston
tells him that the reckoning he will
suffer in the next film is at hand
we see winston make a phone call to make
jon xcommunicado and he must give an
identification number to certify the
order
one one one one one that feels like an
awfully low identification number
meant to evoke the idea that winston has
been around for a long time
longer than probably several members of
the high table and definitely longer
than whoever the elder is
since he appears to be younger than even
john wick time means history
and history begets secrets so winston
must have a lot of them
we can't really be sure how long this
underworld system is operated
the only clue we have to the
organization's age is the displayed gold
coin in barata's compound
he doesn't say how old it is only that
it was extraordinarily difficult to
track down
considering the sheer amount of people
registered in the system of this
universe however
only five digits in an id number and all
ones at that
means he could be somewhere close to the
foundational infrastructure of the
underworld as we understand it in the
movies
winston can pretty much have a claim to
a catchphrase when he says that the
rules are what separate us from the
animals multiple times across
all three films exactly rules
without them we live with the animals is
that the voice of experience does he
remember a time before the rules he also
tells the adjudicator that his loyalties
extend far beyond the continental
possibly beyond the jurisdiction of the
table itself
the biggest question for winston's
background is where the friendly
relationship with jon begins
and now possibly ends it's frequently
stated and even occasionally leveraged
against winston that he is pretty fond
of jon
but understanding why is a game of
speculative leaps of logic
they don't appear to have much in common
since john's rather a hothead and
winston is savage in his calm icy
attitudes towards others
have a drink
and relax
for now winston gave john a marker at
the end of john wick too
a marker that is yet to be identified or
cashed in as well as the hour head start
to get away
winston appears to owe jon a favor and
the stakes have not gotten high enough
yet for jon to feel like cashing it in
winston knows john well enough to hold
his sense of internal honor and
emotional state against him
as he does when asking which version of
jon he wants to die before confronting
the adjudicator
who do you wish to die as the baba yaga
the last thing many men ever see or as a
man
we don't know if the result which puts
john over a balcony to fall four stories
is a double triple or even quadruple
cross
but it nonetheless proves a level of
intimacy between the two men
in any other context you wouldn't
hesitate to call them friends
winston displayed total willingness to
break rules for jon
up until he was forced to declare him
excommunicado in this universe
that comes from trust earned off the
back of taking risks for each other
the tale waiting to be told between them
will likely be part of the plot for both
the fourth and fifth movies in the
franchise
is it a display of the ultimate trust to
undermine the table
or an ultimate betrayal to leave john to
the wolves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you